Democrats battle it out for supremacy on
the undercard and we prepare for the
bigger fight on the main card I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
bienvenidos amigos ala Ben Shapiro show
donde no habla espanol there are
normally a most a las personas que
piensan que si I know you thought you
were listening the democratic debate
last night so the democratic debate is a
thing that happened last night and I
didn't drink cyanide which was my
prediction yesterday so not all of my
predictions come true I survived it I
feel like I should get one of those one
of those t-shirts that says I survived
the first democratic debate and all I
got was this lousy t-shirt but I'll tell
you who didn't survive it was beta
O'Rourke
basically they wheeled his prone body
out of the room after this mate so we're
going to go through all of the various
candidates did they have a good night
did they have a bad night I'll tell you
who the big winner was last night
Donald J Trump after you'd had a great
night last night because this was not
just a clown car this was all of the
clowns popped out of the car and then
started ramming each other with foam
pillows that's it that this was all of
the clowns decided to stuff themselves
back into a phone booth and then wrestle
with one another no one looks good
everyone looked stupid and one thing
that became deeply apparent is that the
entire Democratic Party with maybe the
exception of Joe Biden when Joe Biden's
the only sane person in your party you
are jack man but the Democratic Party
has decided that the only reason they
exist is to pander to the political
geniuses on Twitter the polls show that
the vast majority of Democrats are
fairly moderate in their views on
everything from abortion yes they are in
favor of some restrictions on abortion
to Medicare they are not in favor of
Medicare for all they want to keep their
private health care plans the vast
majority of Democrats are fairly
moderate on immigration they do want to
see our border police and yet the
entirety of the democratic party last
night competed to see who could say the
most insane extreme thing in the
stupidest possible way now one of the
joys of watching these debates is
watching some of the tough tough
balloons of these politicians just
explode and beta O'Rourke really had the
roughest night yeah it's hard to say who
won because no
really ended up the big winner but there
was a very clear loser everyone to it
and that clear loser was beta
now the reason that beta was the clear
loser is because he was the easiest
target
there's only polling at three or four
percent he still has scads of money in
his back pocket but he was polling
really badly and one of the reasons that
he was pulling really badly is because
he had been built up so much during his
Senate race with Ted Cruz so he runs
against Ted Cruz who is in an unlikable
politician a lot of people think that
that he is unlikable the media obviously
despised him in a deep and profound way
and because the media despised him in
this deep and profound way they decided
to build up a dough as though beta was a
thing there are stories on him the HBO
did an entire documentary running with
bado which is just the worst thing that
ever was and they suggested that he was
charismatic look at how amazing he is it
just goes to show you that when the
media build-up somebody is charismatic
three-quarters of that is the media
building somebody up as charismatic not
actual charisma and bado was just ripe
for the plucking here bado was ready to
fall he was he was Mike Tyson before
Buster Douglas and then Buster Douglas
came along and then Mike Tyson started
losing every other fight and that is
what has happened with bait o O'Rourke
they know or ork
is toast and all the other candidates
are gonna make hay out of simply
punching him in the face over and over
and over as we will see okay so we're
going to get to all of the highlights
and the lowlights the joy and the
despair the laughter and the tears the
pregnant men guess that's a thing that
happened and all of the other stupidity
but first good blinds are to a home what
a good tie is to suit it brings it all
together you know your house it may look
like crap and you're like everything
else here is nice why does my house look
like crap it's because you didn't
actually look at the stuff that's
covering your windows you should and you
should replace it the best way with
blinds com they make it really fast and
really easy to shop for window coverings
this is why I like them with 15 million
windows covered over 30,000 five-star
customer reviews blinds calm is
America's number-one online retailer for
affordable quality custom window
coverings every single order gets free
samples free shipping a free online
design consultation you just send them
pictures of your house they send back
custom recommendations from a
professional from what will work with
your color scheme your furniture
specific rooms they will even send you
samples to make sure that everything
looks as good in person as it does
online they've really made it easy for
you so there's no excuse to leave up
those mangled blinds or worse have no
blinds at all because that's not a great
idea for a limited time my listeners get
$20 off at blinds.com
when you use promo code bed that is
blinds.com promo code ben for $20 off
faux wood blinds cellular shades roller
shades and more blinds.com promo code
ben go check them out right now rules
and regulations do apply go check them
out it's a great deal 20 bucks off at
blinds.com
when you use promo code Ben cover up
those winners make your house look
better I promise you're not gonna regret
it blinds.com promo code Ben okay so we
begin last night with bado
falling so bado is basically jump 2016
so Jeb came into the race he was the
front runner and then Donald Trump
really just pummeled living crap out of
him and so did everybody else every so
often somebody needed a boost and Jeb
Bush was like the cocaine of that race
like if anybody needed a bump they just
went over to Jeb Bush punched him and
then gained a couple of points in the
polls
well bado is that so bado is highly
irritating to everyone because he's so
puffed up and has such a sense of his
own grandeur after losing a Senate race
which is his only qualification for
running for president of the United
States after believing that the media
were on his side I mean you have to feel
a little bad for Beta Beta because the
fact is that everybody told him how
wonderful he was until the minute he
wasn't running against Ted Cruz anymore
and then they're like yeah that guy is
any kind of annoying
doesn't he have these weird mannerisms
he's in his personal history kind of odd
isn't he a rich boy playing it man of
the people you got to feel bad for him a
little bit because he's standing there
going wait I'm the same person I was
breath I'm who I was five seconds
ago why are you ripping on me I'm just
here ripping this bong why are you
ripping on me brah
and that's how it went so the debate
opens last night and bado is asked a
question about his preferred tax rate
baito dodges the question by jumping
into speaking Spanish and Cory Booker
gives him some of the most epic side-eye
in history so Cory Booker mr. Potatohead
didn't just bring his angry eyes last
night he also brought his side eyes last
night and the visuals were astounding
here's what it sounded like
perhaps want a marginal individual tax
rate of 70% on the very highest earners
those making more than 10 million
dollars a year would you support that
and if not what would your top
individual rate be necesitamos in career
cada persona en el éxito de este po no
Meah
pero si quiere Moses era so necesitamos
include cada persona in Westra
democracia kurivolt are Cavalcante this
is cory booker look at Emily Elizabeth
Warren is like what is going on and Cory
Booker it's like I can't believe I have
to learn Mandarin before the next debate
visit this is it's so funny he's asked a
question in English and peyto just
starts riffing on all of this I mean
basically the I think the best part of
this is that he avoided the question in
Spanish so he didn't actually answer the
question in Spanish he avoided the
question in Spanish which by the way I
think is actually a pretty great tactic
I think that next time somebody asks
Cory Booker or well or beta or anybody
on stage who speak Spanish next time
somebody asked them a question in
English they don't like they should just
say you'll know ah blowing glass yeah
like I don't get it man I don't speak
English and then this just launched into
his long speech in Spanish Cory Booker
looking unimpressed at bado Spanish is
one of the great is one of the great
moments I mean this screen cap is the
meme everybody looking at bata like what
is going but don't worry as we will see
Cory Booker himself also awkwardly spoke
Spanish this became sort of the theme of
the night I'm gonna have to show you
that real fast so here's cory booker
also awkwardly speaking spanish it turns
out that the side-eye that Booker was
casting at bado
was just because he was mad that Beto's
spoke Spanish before he did in fact both
Booker and Beto's spoke Spanish before
Huli and Castro the actual Hispanic
person in the race so here is Cory
Booker speaking Spanish both of them by
the way I have been told my Spanish as
you can tell is not good both of them
I've been told speak Spanish not
particularly well so this got kind of
awkward what would you do on day one and
this is a situation that the next
president will inherit the situation our
order is in
tabla este Presidente attack Tavo demon
asado los immigrant Asus inacceptable a
voyeur can be arrested on day one I will
make sure that number one we end the ice
policies and the customs and border
policies are violating the human rights
ok so again the speaking of the Spanish
now the only person who was really
disturbed by this the most disturbed
person was Elizabeth Warren she truly
wanted to get in on the act if she is
the least diverse person on the stage so
the act that she wanted to get in on she
was I promise you you looked at her she
was five seconds away from trying to
speak Cherokee she was so close to
breaking out the Navajo wind talking it
was like this far away of her Lord okay
so so bado
starts the debate this way and then
baitul gets clubbed by bill de blasio
you know getting clubbed by frankenstein
is it's it's got to be an unpleasant
experience I mean bill de blasio is
eight foot three gawky awkward a serial
groundhog murderer and Bill DeBlasio
standing there slamming bata why why is
he slamming bata what's the rip on bata
the rip on bado is he's to moderate why
because bado didn't call for the total
nationalization of health care and the
banning of private health care plans no
no one last night attacked Elizabeth
Warren the reason no one attacked
Elizabeth Warren is because I think
everybody sort of understood that if you
attacked Warren it was likely to
backfire because the media loved Warren
right now she is their golden girl and
they are going that's not a reference to
her age they were going to the they were
then going to protect her there's this
patina of freshness about Elizabeth
Warren despite the fact she's not a
fresh politician and if anybody clocked
her it was going to backfire on them
instead
why not beat up I'm a guy that
everybody's beating up on who's still
pulling kind of low let's all beat up on
on bado and that was the theme of the
night basically anybody who beat up on
bado benefited so here's bill de blasio
slamming bado for not calling for total
nationalization of health care would you
replace private insurance no I think the
choice is is fundamental to our ability
to get private insurance is not working
for tens of millions of Americans when
you talk about the co-pays the
deductibles the premiums the
out-of-pocket expenses it's not working
not working they can choose Medicare for
the coordinating workers in your people
they're able to keep them their private
health insurance okay this is amazing so
bill de blasio is clocking bado Beto's
exactly right here by the way bado is
saying that a public option meaning that
people can opt in to Medicare which is
still a bad idea but he's saying that a
public option is a better more popular
option than simply banning private
health insurance considering a hundred
and seventy seven million Americans are
in private health insurance and the vast
majority of them are actually happy with
the care they get from their private
health insurers but baito is not
sufficiently woke and so begins the runs
of the left as we will see this becomes
a theme over the course of the debate
everyone running a headlong into the
left right over that cliff like Marxist
lemmings pretty spectacular I'll get to
that in just a second first this fourth
of July in addition to drinking pure
liquid freedom because murica the only
thing Americans should be drinking is
black rifle coffee black rifle coffees
awesome okay have black rifle coffee
every single morning not only do I have
black rifle coffee I love the dudes who
run black rifle coffee they are awesome
the company was founded by former
Special Operations vets black rifle
delivers the best roasts to order coffee
directly to your door this guarantees
that you're getting fresh premium coffee
with every single order black rifles
coffee club makes things easy just pick
your blend in the amount you want and
then a black rifle ships your coffee
direct to your door every month hassle
free Plus when you join their coffee
club you'll receive discounts and offers
not available to other customers when
you drink black rifle coffee you're
supporting a company that gives back to
veteran and first responder causes and
serves coffee and culture to people who
truly love America so no more of that
leftist tripe being served to you and
paper cups at stores that let people go
to the bathroom without buying anything
instead go to black rifle coffee the
most American holiday calls for the most
American coffee black rifle coffee get
20% off your first purchase when you
shop at black rifle coffee calm slash
pen that is black rifle coffee calm
slash pen for 20% off your first
purchase that's black rifle coffee calm
slash pen okay so the consensus was that
bado
fell and fell hard last night that bado
is basically toast now he was basically
toast before but he
came everybody's favorite punching bag
when you are Bill de Blasio's punching
bag how far how far the mighty have
fallen somewhere Jake Gyllenhaal weeps
as he burns his baito shirt all of
Hollywood love bado until five seconds
ago so very very bad night for bata o
ruck now we move on to some of the other
candidates so Elizabeth Warren
how did her ankle well she was the
front-runner coming into the night and
she really had to stand out right the
idea was that she should have dominated
at the expectations for her were high
now she didn't lose the debate shouldn't
really get touched but she didn't stand
out from the rest of these dolts she
just stood on stage and kind of said
stuff and and what she really did do
there were a couple of ways in which he
actually did damage her self not in the
primaries but in the general what was
her to make the general he's we're all
become attack ads and they become attack
ads because Elizabeth Warren has made a
big boo-boo she has made a big boo-boo
everybody in the Democratic Party has
seated you moderate Lane to Joe Biden
everyone it's unbelievable
40% of the Democratic Party still
considers itself moderate to
conservative and all of these other
dimwits these numbskulls are ceding that
40 percent to Joe Biden and clubbing
each other over whether we should
provide tax payer mandate a borscht
mandated abortions for animals or
whether we should or whether it should
provide illegal immigrants with not only
health care but subsidized New York
lofts I mean that's what the debate
turned into and Elizabeth Warren was
leading that charge okay so Elizabeth
Warren comes in and she oh she has to do
is handle herself decently she did that
she's not gonna lose any points but she
certainly didn't gain any points last
night she didn't win running away or
anything like that
and she did do herself some damage if
Democrats ever get to a general election
if she ever gets to a general election
so Elizabeth Warren it starts off this
way she's asked about whether she would
ever have any limits on abortion there
was unanimity across this stage that not
a single Democrat would limit abortion
under any circumstances 18 percent of
Americans agree with that proposal 82%
of Americans disagree with that proposal
it was unanimous on stage because this
party has run off the rails to the left
at least the leadership not the people
vote for it
the leaders
has run off the rails to the left what
she's about to say is wild any limits on
abortion I would make certain that every
woman has access to the full range of
reproductive health care services and
that includes birth control it includes
abortion it includes everything for a
woman it's not enough for us to expect
the courts to protect us 47 years ago
Roe vs. Wade was decided and we've all
looked to the courts all that time as
state after state has undermined Roe has
put in exceptions has come right up to
the edge of taking away protection as a
senator all she is a ball of nervous
energy on that stage calling for
government intervention in every aspect
of American life so the question was
would you put any limits on abortion
that her answer was not only would I not
put limits I would fund it and federally
mandated funding via the legislature
she's pretty incredible stuff she does
so much of these debates is about the
aesthetics of it and Elizabeth Warren
basically is rabbit from Winnie the Pooh
she just runs around worrying about
everything and she has a plan for her
garden and she's irritating I mean I'm
sorry I said it yesterday I will say it
again she's an irritating human being a
mikolavich art is not an irritating
human being this is not about the sex of
the person I'm speaking about Amy
Klobuchar is not irritating human being
tulsi gabbard is not an irritating human
being both of them last I checked for
women they self-identify that way so
that's all that matters these days in
any case Elizabeth Warren again she's
wearing well with the media class but
I'm not sure this stuff is gonna wear
well with the American public I mean
listen to her talk so they asked a
question on stage how many of you would
abolish private health insurance
understand no one wants private health
insurance abolished in the United States
the number of people who want private
health insurance abolished in the United
States it's in like the 20% range no one
wants this which is why when this
question is asked only two hands go up
for abolishing a private health
insurance bill deblasio in actual
communist and Elizabeth Warren it want
to be communist who used to say that she
was a capitalist and used to talk about
the glories of the free market and how
we make that free market work better
that was her sort of pitch well now
she's run all the way to the left why
because she's trying to head off Burnie
at the past she feels like if she can
cannibalize Burnie and then eat his
desiccated old body then she will take
over his wing of the party now maybe
that's a good strategy
for a primary I don't know that enough
voters there but it's certainly not a
good strategy for a general election you
think this won't be an ad you think the
Donald Trump won't be able to say
Elizabeth Warren wants you to lose your
health insurance because she does that's
what she's saying right here a hundred
and seventy seven million Americans over
90 percent of Americans are happy with
the health insurance that they currently
have now or at least they have health
insurance again 19 well over 90 percent
of Americans have health insurance and
something like 70 percent of all
Americans have privately provided health
insurance hey well here is Elizabeth
Warren raising her hand when asked if
she would abolish private health
insurance so everyone who's listening to
this you me all of us we wouldn't have
private health insurance we'd be forced
into the Medicare system which is
already underfunded overburdened and
would quickly run into the bankruptcy
numbers extraordinarily fast meaning
we'll be bankrupt by the end of the
2020s anyway so I guess we can
accelerate that and make a bankrupt next
year by throwing a bunch of people onto
it without properly funding it and then
I suppose we'll have to cram down on
doctors who they can care for and who
they can't that's the other half of this
and then folks on the left you say well
you know doctors voluntarily take
Medicare right now bright because they
can choose not to or they can choose to
do so if Medicare is the only system
that means that Medicare is the sole
bargaining entity with doctors and that
means that the government can cram down
basically whatever they want on doctors
and then doctors will be forced to take
it or they'll be forced to drop out of
the doctoring business and that's that's
effectively what Elizabeth Warren is
arguing for here she's not arguing for a
public option she's not arguing that you
should be able to buy government health
insurance or use government health
insurance as an alternative to the
private markets a proposition I think
leads gradually and inevitably toward
nationalized health care but which is
not nationalized health care she's
arguing for the full abolition of
private health care in the United States
good luck with this one in a general the
issue of health care right now I really
try to understand whether may or may not
be daylight between you many people
watching at home have health insurance
words through their employer who here
would abolish their private health
insurance in favor of a government-run
plan just a show of hands start off with
okay so no one else on stage would
abolish their own private insurance to
take a government plan bill de blasio
would because that dude is happy to
mooch off the government all the time
Elizabeth Warren is a cynical lady and
so what she is doing there is trying to
head off Bernie at the pass in fact
during the debate she suggested that she
like Bernie is for Medicare for all it
was a pretty obvious appeal and that
wasn't the extent of Warren's extremism
on the stage this is a lady who is
solely concerned with knocking Bernie
out early and then pivoting to the
middle but there's one problem there's a
thing and it's called video and it
exists now and thirty years ago you
could do this routine where you
basically lied to the American people in
either the primaries or the general now
you ran to the extreme and then you
shifted to the middle for the general
election but in today's day and age what
you say in the primaries matters most of
the quotes that people have from
President Trump occurred during the
primaries the primaries outlive the
primaries they didn't use to but they do
now so when Warren is asked about gun
confiscation and she basically signals
that yeah she might be interested in
having the government coming to our
house and take guns is this gonna play
in a general I have some serious doubts
government needs to go and figure out a
way to get the guns that are already out
there what do you think we need to do is
we need to treat it like a serious
research problem which we have not done
you know guns in the hands of a
collector who's had them for decades
who's never fired them who take safety
seriously that's very different from
guns that are sold and turned over
quickly we can't treat this is it across
the board problem we have to treat it
like a public health emergency
that means bring data to bear and it
means make real change in this country
thank you whether it's politically
popular or not
okay so again she avoids the question
because the actual answer is yes I would
try to confiscate guns she could just
answer it but she even even Elizabeth
Warren understands that she can't say
that one out loud well in a second we'll
get sue the rest of the Democratic
candidates and also I have a question I
have a question there were two terms
that did not come up on stage last night
nearly at all and it's pretty incredible
and it shows where the Democratic Party
is
first I'm on the internet basically 24
hours a day I'm sleeping I'm still on
the internet I'm concerned about hackers
stealing my data because you should be
too and that's why I trust expressvpn to
protect my online activity you should
too hackers government Internet
companies basically everyone they're all
looking for your data they're looking to
gobble it up expressvpn runs in the
background of your computer or phone and
then you just use the internet the way
you normally would you download the app
you click to connect voila you are now
protected by their powerful encryption
technology
I never go online without expressvpn you
shouldn't either expressvpn is the
fastest VPN I've tried it cost less than
seven bucks a month it comes with a
30-day money-back guarantee stop hackers
Big Brother Internet companies from
grabbing all your data take back that
online privacy the way I did
use Express VPN protect your online
activity today seriously it's very
important find out how you can get three
months for free and expressvpn calm
slash Ben that's exp ress VPN comm slash
man for three months free with one year
package visit expressvpn comm slash Ben
to learn more online security is deeply
important if you think they're not out
to get your data you are wrong go check
them out right now expressvpn comm slash
been three months free with one year
package okay so there are two terms that
did not come up last night and then
we'll get to the rest of these
candidates there were two terms that did
not come up last night Obama and Trump
and that's kind of shocking Obama didn't
come up because the democratic party has
left him behind
this is the biggest problem for Joe
Biden is that Joe Biden tonight will be
on stage trying to defend Barack Obama's
record and he has a record to defend and
that record isn't great people don't
like Obamacare Obamacare has been
unworkable people don't like Obama's
foreign policy particularly much that
was unworkable Joe Biden will have to
defend that there's a reason none of the
Democrats were out there paying homage
to Barack Obama that's because his
presidency was not very good he did not
do a lot of good things for people and
so people have sort of been ignoring the
fact that Obama was president for eight
years more oddly the other term that did
not come up a lot last night was Trump
and that's really interesting because I
think that I assume that the calculus
for these Democrats is that they all
thought that the other Democrats were
going to attack Trump and so they were
going to distinguish themselves by
talking about policy but instead they're
sort of a prisoner's dilemma and they
all ended
talking about their crazy insane
out-of-the-box policy instead of talking
about the one thing that unifies their
party and unifies a lot of Americans
hatred for President Trump Trump's name
was mentioned only 20 times in two hours
which is a very very low number for an
incumbent president running against a
field of millions that's kind of
astonishing the other reason they're not
attacking Trump of course is that his
actual record is pretty good this debate
started with a bunch of Democrats
proclaiming to the skies that the
economy is actually bad now no one
actually believes that no one actually
believes that the that the economy is
bad in this in this cycle it just isn't
the economy is very strong Elizabeth
Warren was complaining that only people
at the top were making money off this
economy that is absolutely untrue we've
seen wage increases faster than they
have done for years we've seen the
unemployment rate at record lows we've
seen black unemployment at record lows
Hispanic unemployment at record lows we
have seen real economic growth under
this president like him or hate him that
is a fact
and the Democrats somehow have to avoid
that and I guess they didn't want to
discuss Trump because if they did it
might remind people that Trump is still
out there and then there's the final
problem discussing Trump and that is
that all of these Democrats next to each
other they look like Lilliputians Donald
Trump is an outsized personality he is
there's a tendency for people who are
president to make themselves feel
indispensable in daily life feel like
they occupy the vacuum like they're just
there all the time Barack Obama did this
he was very effective at doing this he
made it so it's almost impossible to
think of government or the presidency
without thinking of Obama Trump has done
the same thing except even more so
because he has dominated media coverage
so thoroughly so when you think of any
of those Democrats standing up against
President Trump Trump looks 10 feet tall
and these Democrats look like
Lilliputians maybe that's because
they're still in the primaries maybe
they emerge but the only major figure in
the Democratic Party right now is Joe
Biden all these other people are minor
players and you can see that last night
as they haggled over which groups to
pander to so cory booker mr. Potatohead
he went out there he took out his angry
eyes he slapped him on and then he
started talking about the various groups
that have been left behind now again
it's amazing the Democratic Party
requires a bunch of blue collar white
people to vote for it if they want to
win the presidency in 2020 but the
groups that they keep talking to are the
smallest minority groups that they can
find so they just keep breaking
Americans down into these smaller and
smaller identity groups and then overtly
appealing to them maybe to look
sympathetic I guess or maybe because
they really believe they can out woke
everybody else on the stage so Cory
Booker tried to out woke everybody by
saying you know who we don't appeal to
black people which of course is utterly
untrue the Democratic Party is severely
concerned and supremely concerned with
the interests of its black electorate
which is why Cory Booker's on the stage
because Cory Booker is not a good
candidate but presumably his entire
pitch is to the black community don't
vote for that old white guy who used to
hang out with segregationist I mean this
what he said last week vote instead for
me well Cory Booker then went even
further and he said you know we really
have not spent enough time on black
trans people so eventually he's gonna
find the person who he feels we really
have not spent enough time on the black
lesbian trans little person who is half
Native American and also 1/4 Korean
that's where that will be Cory Booker's
constituent but the strategy that says
ignore the vast bulk of the American
electorate to focus on small segments of
the electorate and suggest that those
small segments of the electorate are
being ignored if you cobble enough of
them together you have a coalition good
luck with that Cory Booker civil rights
is someplace to begin but in the
african-american civil rights community
another place to focus on was to stop
the lynching of African Americans we do
not talk enough about trans Americans
especially african-american trans
American
the incredibly high rates of murder
right now we don't talk enough about how
many children about 30% of LGBTQ kids
who do not go to school because of fear
it's not enough just to be on the
Equality Act I'm an original co-sponsor
we need to have a president that will
fight to protect LGBTQ Americans every
single day that's definitely gonna win
him back Ohio right there that right
there is definitely gonna win him back
Ohio okay by the way I will just point
out that there's a factual error in what
he says he talks about the murder rates
against transgender Americans and you
know who has done a lot of research on
this he points out that there were 26
murders of transgender people last year
the vast bulk of them had to do with
were actually not were actually black
transgender people who were killed by
other members of minority groups there
was there's a serious sexual violence
problem against people who are engaged
in the sex industry in other words
prostitution there are a lot of
cross-cutting issues here and Cory
Booker just makes it into America's
racist America's terrible America hates
gay people it's absolute nonsense but I
guess this is the pitch and he wasn't in
but but this was his breakout moment
right I mean he was out walking people
the general consensus wisdom is that
Cory Booker did well last night the
other candidate who consensus wisdom
suggested did well last night was who
Leanne Castro why because he also tried
to out woke everybody how woke is who
Leanne Castro Julian Castro is so woke
that he believes that federally funded
abortions should be available not just
for women for the entirety of the
pregnancy but also for men seriously he
said this last night he said that
biological men should have a
taxpayer-funded right to abortion which
is gonna be weird I mean I got to admit
that's gonna be weird giving an
ultrasound to a man's prostate looking
for a baby is going to be a weird thing
deciding how to perform an abortion
through a man's urethra is gonna be very
odd but hey if anybody can make this
happen who lien Castro can hear he was
last night explaining that biological
men require abortion too would you a
plan cover abortion mr. secretary I
guess it would I don't believe only in
reproductive freedom I believe in
reproductive justice
you know what that means is that just
because a woman or let's also not forget
someone in the trans community a
transfer male if poor doesn't mean they
shouldn't have the right to exercise
that right to choose and so I would
point out a trans female is a biological
male so it's a screw up yeah I'm sure he
meant a trans male meaning a female a
biological female who believes that she
is a male but he said any trans female
so presumably he also wants to make sure
that a male who that that Caitlyn Jenner
can have the abortion that Caitlyn
Jenner so desperately needs this
Democratic Party I'm gonna say I think
they may be slightly out of touch with
mainstream America just a little bit
just a little bit and it infected the
entire party last night was pretty
amazing
don't get to more of that in just one
second first I'm too busy to go to the
post office I will be honest with you
the last time I went to the post office
I got a giant parking ticket cuz there's
only one thing that la authoritative in
parking tickets cleaning up the homeless
problem policing crap nope parking
tickets boom right on it so this is why
I've decided no more of the post office
instead I'm gonna go to stamps calm it
is fast and it is easy
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US Postal Service
directly to your computer whether you're
a small office sending invoices or an
online seller shipping out products or
even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day stamps com can handle it
all with ease simply use your computer
to print official US postage 24/7 for
any letter any package in any class of
mail anywhere you want to send it once
your mail is ready just hand it off to
the mail carrier or drop it in the
mailbox
it is indeed that simple with stamps
calm you get five cents off every
first-class stamp and up to 40% off
Priority Mail over 700,000 small
businesses are to use stamps calm and
daily wire is one of them I use stamps
calm personally right now my listeners
get a special offer it includes a four
week trial plus free postage and digital
scale no long term commitment just go to
stamps com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage type in Shapiro
that is stamp set comm enter Shapiro
okay we'll get to more of the Democratic
debates in just one second plus we will
preview tonight's Democrats have a lot
coming up you have to go subscribe daily
we're calm $9.99 a month get the
subscription you can see the rest of
this show gives you two additional hours
of the show everyday get the annual
Suren you also get the very greatest in
beverage vessels this right here the
leftist year is how to call tumblr it is
a magical magical vessel so grab that
because they're gonna be lots of leftist
tears over the coming weeks is they
realize these debates are a complete
crap show we'll get to all of that and
just to say also subscribe because it
helps protect us against the
vicissitudes of the big tech companies
against the vicissitudes of the evil
malicious Media Matters left it seeks to
destroy all opposing viewpoints by going
after advertisers help us out by
subscribing go over to Daley we're calm
make it happen it's pretty great we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so the woke fest continued with bill de
blasio the mayor of New York then
declaring that while cory booker may be
a black man and while hue and castro may
be calling for abortions for biological
men he is the father of a biracial son
and that means that he is woke in and of
himself go for bill de blasio i run the
largest police force in america - and if
we're going to stop these shootings we
won't get these guns off the street we
have to have a very different lationship
between our police and our community I
also want to say there's something that
sets me apart from all my colleagues
running in this race
that is for the last 21 years I've been
raising a black son in America and I
have had to have very very serious talks
with my son Dante about how to protect
himself on the streets of our city and
all over this country including how to
deal with the fact that he has to take
special caution because there been too
many tragedies between our young men and
our police - okay so he's trying out
woke everybody by saying sure I'm a
giant white guy but I have a biracial
son and that means that I'm I'm even
more victimized in America than Cory
Booker who's a black person on the stage
so it's just it was a woke fest last
night maybe this works in a primary it's
a theory maybe it works in the Twitter
primary consensus seemed to be the de
Blasio did okay that Castro had a big
breakout because he wants men to have
abortions that Cory Booker did great
yesterday for some reason I guess
basically everybody who's most woke did
best Amy Klobuchar I tried to get into
the act right Amy Klobuchar who was
supposed to be the moderate who's gonna
rival Joe Biden she was the most
interesting candidate in the field
before she announced then she decided
I'm gonna slide on over to the left so
she was asked about decriminalizing
illegal immigration so there's a big
controversy that is now broken out about
the about so-called section 1325 Cooley
and Castro attacked brutally bethe
O'Rourke suggesting the beta of work was
not in fact woke enough on illegal
immigration that in fact section 1325
which criminalizes the illegal
immigration you cross the border that's
now considered a criminal misdemeanor if
you do so between ports of entry you
show up at a port of entry you apply for
asylum
that's totally legal you try to cross
the Rio Grande River that is a
misdemeanor the reason that that's a
misdemeanor is because we are trying to
drive people toward the ports of entry
because if they don't go to the ports of
entry you know it happens sometimes they
die because a lot
or dangerous to go over the Rio Grande
than it is to walk to a port of entry
naturally the Democrats want to get rid
of that provision of US law and make it
so that it's only like a civil fine if
you cross the Rio Grande illegally
I suppose they think that won't
incentivize people to cross illegally
between ports of entry what do they
think that's going to do Amy claw bat
writer who should know better
says that she would consider
decriminalizing illegal immigration
let's talk about what secretary Castro
just said he wants to no longer have it
be a crime to illegally cross the border
do you support that do you think it
should be a civil offense only and if so
do you worry about potentially
incentivizing people to come here
immigrants they do not diminish America
they are America and I am happy to look
at his proposal but I do think you want
to make sure that you have provisions in
place that allow you to go after
traffickers and allow you to go after
people who are violating the law okay so
yeah there she is being somewhat
moderate and just getting thrown out of
the building basically she also pointed
out this is gonna be again an attack ad
by Trump against the other Democrats
who's Amy Klobuchar Democratic senator
suggesting to Elizabeth Warren and Bill
DeBlasio guys kicking half of Americans
off their health care maybe that's a bad
idea maybe that's a bad pitch in a
general election one of the Democrats
who wants to keep private insurance in
addition to a government health care
plan why is an incremental approach in
your view better than a sweeping overall
I think it's a bold approach it's
something that Barack Obama wanted to do
when we were working on the Affordable
Care Act and that is a public option I
am just simply concerned about kicking
half of America off of their health
insurance in four years which is exactly
what this bill says okay so I mean that
is going to be an attack yet I mean she
mccr attic senator openly acknowledging
that they're talking about kicking 177
million people off of their health
insurance shouldn't win any points for
that you know who else didn't win any
points last night Tim Ryan the Congress
person from Ohio
he's also slightly trying to edge into
the moderate lane but doing himself no
favors here was Tim Ryan explaining that
Democrats are out of touch with common
people
after which Julian Castro and Cory
Booker
decided to fight over their black trans
disabled little person constituent we
have a perception problem with the
Democratic Party we are not connecting
to the working-class people in the very
states that I represent in Ohio in the
industrial Midwest
we've lost all connection that we have
got to change the center of gravity of
the Democratic Party from being coastal
and illegal elitist and Ivy League
which is the perception to somebody from
the forgotten communities that have been
left behind for the last thirty years to
get those workers back on our side if we
don't address that fundamental problem
with our connection to workers white
black brown gay straight working-class
people comes none of this is going to
get done Chuck okay
and that is the only pitch that matters
and that's the one that they are all
going to ignore now the other big
exchange of the debate that was getting
all sorts of attention was in exchange
between Tim Ryan and Tulsi Gabbard so
Tulsi Gabbard who is a congressperson
from Hawaii and also Assad's favorite
senator so Bashar Assad has a very warm
relationship with Tulsi Gabbard that she
is not just an isolationist on foreign
policy and a refugee from the x-men
apparently she's got this amazingly
awesome shock of gray hair in the middle
of it if a completely black haircut it's
pretty it's pretty great actually
she and and Tim Ryan went at it and
Tulsi Gabbard I mean the fact that this
stuff gets sheared on national debate
stages is pretty astonishing Tim Ryan
points out that the war in Afghanistan
was justified because of 9/11
at which point Tulsi Gabbard says what
did the Taliban ever do to us and she
gets cheered the reality of it is that
the United States isn't engaged the
Taliban will grow and they will have
bigger bolder terrorist acts we have got
to have some present there is this
out there long before we came in yeah
and there yeah
well we keep us and they will be wanting
to Afghanistan thinking that we're going
to somehow squash this Taliban I didn't
sitting there they say squash them when
we weren't in there they started flying
planes into our buildings so I'm just
saying right now attacked us on 9/11
outside of it well I understand why I
and so many other people joined the
military to go after the Taliban that's
why we joined to go after al-qaeda and
not the Taliban like um the Taliban was
protecting al Qaeda that was the whole
premise of the war in Afghanistan George
W Bush offered the Taliban the
opportunity to turn over Osama bin Laden
and to allow us to go after al-qaeda
they refused and so we wrecked them so
again the fact that that was cheered and
that Tim Ryan has cast out good luck
with this Democratic Party guys now the
truth is that the best metaphor for all
of this was the mic breakdown that
happened in the middle of the debate so
in the middle of the debate NBC really
blew it some sound guy is about to get
fired today
because in the middle of this debate
they the backstage audio could start
being hurt and honestly I was kind of
gritting my teeth because as somebody
who works in this industry and has a
microphone on me a lot of times I'm
always counting on the audio guy not to
have the mic on when I don't want it on
so that people don't hear me going to
the bathroom for example well basically
that's what happened on NBC news last
night should there be a role for the
federal government in mike serone
everybody's mics are on I think we have
a I heard that too that's okay I think
we had a little mic issue in the back
control room we've got we have the I
think we heard yeah we have the audience
all you
what's happening we are hearing our
colleagues audio guess what guys we are
gonna take a quick break we're gonna get
this technical situation fixed we will
be right back very very awkward Donald
Trump tweeted out about it this really
makes Donald Trump mad the production of
coffee
you gotta love the fact that Trump
because he was a TV star all he cared
about last night was the production
quality he tweeted out NBC News and
MSNBC should be ashamed of themselves
for having such a horrible technical
breakdown in the middle of the debate
truly unprofessional and only worthy of
a fake news organization which they are
they screw up the mics and he's like
that wasn't even his best tweet his best
tweet last night was about half an hour
into the bait and he just tweeted out
one word all caps buying fact check true
fact check true mr. president the term
campaign then released a statement
saying that the debate was the best
argument for president Trump's
reelection that is 100% true campaign
spokesperson Kaylie mcenany said quote
this debate was the best argument for
president Trump's re-election and should
really be counted as an in-kind
contribution to the president's campaign
the Democrats proposed a radical
government takeover of the American
society that would demolish the American
Dream so many are gaining access to
under the growing Trump economy the far
left socialist policies Democrats
embrace tonight were akin to a mutual
political suicide pact they want to
throw 200 million people off their
current private health care plans put
them into a government-run system that
would eliminate choice and crush
innocent Americans with an enormous tax
burden to pay for it these Democrat
policies which feature government
control over virtually every aspect of
Americans lives there are striking
resemblances to those from authoritarian
regimes like Cuba and Venezuela perhaps
it's fitting Democrats held their first
debate in Miami Florida where so many
Latinos have fled the ravages of
socialism and understand its devastating
effects on society in a real and
personal way okay this is true I mean if
you watch that debate last night and you
are anywhere close to the middle of the
American spectrum I can't imagine this
won you over now that's not the goal of
these primary debates presumably the
goal is to appeal to the far left but
but that far left may not be that big
and Joe Biden thinks that right so team
Joe tweeted out last night in the middle
of the debate
let's be clear we shouldn't tear the
Affordable Care
town we should build on it the Biden
administration will give every American
the right to choose a public option like
Medicare to ensure everyone has access
to the quality affordable health care
they deserve
hashtag dem debate and so that is Biden
militating against Elizabeth Warren
going directly at her and at Bernie
Sanders so Biden knows which lane he is
in apparently and he is staying in that
lane in that a smart Terry McAuliffe the
former Virginia Governor he said listen
these Democrats are out of touch he is
correct they are out of touch I'm a
little disappointed I think we needed to
have more discussion on those issues
that actually affect Americans every
single day they don't want to hear us
talking about Mitch McConnell and we
spent a lot of time at Medicare fraud
but people sitting home Anderson right
now they're worried about their
prescription drug cost they're worried
about getting in a car and you know
driving and spending I want to have to
go see their kids play a ball game we
needed more discussion on those issues
that effect I thought John Delaney was
that exactly right would he answer that
infrastructure you know prescription
drugs
I didn't hear workforce training at all
tonight one of the biggest issues our
country is right the same same two
primary for people living in the middle
of the country this is the primary for
AOC and here was a OCS take on this
thing she says you know what the big
problem was that they didn't talk
climate change enough that was the big
problem I don't think that we are
discussing climate change the way we
[Music]
a huge broad systemic issue and you
can't just say is Miami gonna exist in
50 years we need to say what are you
gonna do about this and I know there's a
lot of folks a lot of young people that
have been mobilizing for an entire
climate debate in in the Democratic
caucus I mean it's a good idea okay
they're competing for a OCS no they're
not competing for the guy in Ohio or
Wisconsin or Pennsylvania with God's
help Don and Donald tre this is Donald
Trump's prayer with God's help the
Democrats will continue to run down this
path because good luck gang good luck
okay time for some things I like and
then we'll get to some things that I
hate so things that I like today I
mentioned yesterday this is basically
the Dumbo clown car and that the only
question is going to be which Democrat
jumps from that top platform down into
the bucket of water and that means it's
time for me to recommend Dumbo Dumbo is
a great movie the original Dumbo so
here's a little bit of the original
Dumbo trailer the circus certainly more
entertaining in that film than it was
last night dumb old a little elephant
who was all ears
[Music]
assert this used to be farming now it's
a bunch of people competing over Fringe
votes so that's that's very exciting
stuff so that so go watch the movie the
movies fun don't go watch the remake the
remake is apparently pretty bad but the
original movie is still a great movie my
kids still love it because original
Disney as best isn't the original Disney
is really really good stuff okay other
things that I like you're never gonna
believe this you're ready for this
Andrew Cuomo's had a smart thing or at
least a not dumb thing
so Andrew Cuomo was asked specifically
about Alexandra Ocasio Cortez comparing
the situation on America's southern
border to Nazi concentration camps and
Andrew Cuomo elevated himself for a
moment above his brother quit Chris as
the lesser of the less stupid of the
Cuomo brothers here is Andrew Cuomo the
governor of New York ripping into AOC I
think it's a wholly inappropriate
comparison the Holocaust you're talking
about
a tragedy of biblical proportion and one
of the greatest scourge 'iz in history
six million Jews died during the
Holocaust there is no comparison to the
Holocaust me so but for Chris Paul a
good friend of Cuomo finally saying
something not done congratulations sir
it happens once every couple of years
maybe yeah good on you okay other things
that I like so again I mean this is the
day for me praising people who I will
never praise again Stephen Colbert went
after bado and Booker and he has to
because he's an Elizabeth Warren junkie
so here he was yesterday last night
going after beta O'Rourke and Cory
Booker for speaking Spanish and making
fools of themselves the direct question
would you support a 70% individual
marginal tax rate yes/no or pass
Noah blend glaze and when the topic
turned to the border crisis Booker took
bit of Spanish and raised him mucho mas
de Manos although lost immigrant is
inacceptable a boil can be arrested
[Applause]
espanol off okay so yeah it was obvious
that that even the Democrats were pretty
disappointed in the performance of their
candidates last night now tonight is the
big one tonight it's Bernie versus Biden
old man club off basically it's it's
like that that movie where was it
Sylvester Stallone fought Robert DeNiro
it's like that one so it's old people
fighting each other tonight very much
looking forward to that people judge
standing off to the side crying about
South Bend and all this it should be it
should be more of a party tonight Bernie
Sanders by the way has to be feeling
good about himself because elizabeth
warren's did not distinguish herself
from the pack last night Elizabeth Horne
did not have a breakout night and that
means it's time for Bernie we're gonna
come in we're gonna clean up like what
the USSR and Ukraine in 1932 we're gonna
clean the dump pretty dark humor there
so there's Bernie who he's saying he
said last night watch tonight cuz
tonight's the progressive the
progressives turn Elizabeth words like
I've always been progressive he's like
you have not I was here in 1822 you were
not there being progressive I knew Karl
Marx I'm Adam you are know Karl Marx so
here here's Bernie Sanders talking about
Medicare for all which is of course his
pitch and he's taking it back from
Elizabeth Warren the major issue is do
we believe that health care is a human
right we're not now some people do some
people don't I do so I think whether you
are poor or working class or rich you
are entitled to all the health care that
you need because you're an American
that's what I believe this is a
dysfunctional system our health care
outcomes are not as good as people in
other countries we have got to have a
health care system not to make the
insurance companies rich not to make the
drug companies rich but the guarantee
health care to all people in a
cost-effective way that's medicare for
all so if you liked tonight last night
you will
love tonight when you get the best the
cream of the crop the frontrunners in
the Democratic Party I'm sucked you know
what we're gonna have to go to break I
guess I'll see it here later for two
more hours of coverage or I'll see you
here tomorrow we'll recap the whole
thing for you i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
20:19 hola mamacita the first Democratic
presidential primary debate was last
night and everyone started speaking
Spanish we will examine while US
Democrats sohn muy estupido so then my
pal Jamil jivani stops by to explain why
young men get radicalized finally the
mailbag check it out on the Michael
Noel's show